and joining us for more on this is
former border patrol Chief Rodney Scott
we kind of can't get over what's
happening at the Border in the pictures
that we see and often times you'll hear
us say like this is not sustainable this
can't be possible and yet it really has
been going on for so long the border
patrol must be at its Wits
End thank you for having me on again and
the morale of the agents is just tanked
out I spent yesterday down in no Galis
I'm still down here today and uh the
morale is tanked out but we really have
a short memory I think President Biden
campaigned he ran for president on a
platform that he was going to tear down
border security and they've literally
just done exactly what they promised
people also forget sometimes I was part
I was in the bid Administration for
about seven months I participated in
conversations with these people they Tom
homman and Bill right they do not want
to detain people this is not a problem
for them except for the Optics and the
Optics are getting so bad the only
reason that they're doing these NE
negotiations at a national level but
you'll you'll hit on something the
reason the negotiations aren't going
anywhere in the Senate is because the
Republicans know hr2 has it in there
without ending Catch and Release either
through remain in Mexico or some form of
detention this goes on forever and and
depends on what you call sustainable to
to the Democrats this is fine but for
our country this is devastating uh
Democratic senator Mark Warner from
Virginia says the negotiations have
finally gotten serious I I don't know if
they get anything done but they might
want to pull somebody in from the house
to get on these negotiations if they if
they really want to move it forward uh
meanwhile you got Greg Abbott down there
in Texas he sent his first Charter
flight to Chicago I think they about 120
on board uh here is Alderman Raymond
Lopez in Chicago talking about that very
issue my mayor is blaming everyone
except the person who needs to get the
blame and that is President Joe Biden
and kamla Harris they're not calling out
secretary May orcus for letting UND
argumented for letting Asylum Seekers
come to this country under false
pretense and then giving them court
cases 10 years from now it's outrageous
that common sense is nowhere to be found
in the Democratic party anymore when it
comes to this issue yeah here's the
problem Chief is that we we're not
getting anywhere on this you it just
it's this drum beat day after day and
it's only gotten worse in the month of
December what what do you think would
change the president's
mind honestly I don't think anything
will change the president's mind this is
a little bit like the border wall when
he shut down the border wall and and
again I was still the chief at the time
there were conversations behind the
scenes literally how little could the
administration do on construction
without violating the empowerment act
when the courts ordered the
administration to restart remain in
Mexico there were negot there were
discussions behind the scenes of how
little can we do how can we revamp it so
that it doesn't work this Administration
campaigned on this that this is their
core
belief system the only thing that's
going to really change this I think is
November 2024 Americans need to wake up
and I don't who care who the candidate
is they need to vote for a candidate
that supports National Security which is
border security which is your individual
Public Safety well if that's the case
then that's two million more all right
because it's where it is now go ahead I
just this could be fixed today that we
don't by the way we don't need policy
discussions at the national level this
was a policy that Biden put in place
Biden could fix it today by signing a
document that put remain in Mexico back
in place and 80% of this would be over
with everything is is semantics and show
that's why I believe the only thing that
will change is an election all right
Rodney Scott thank you appreciate it
Merry Christmas to you thank you Chief
I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis